welcome to this video oj three from
Norway let's see Queens gambit okay I'd
like to play first those moves and then
see for later check yeah this is not the
most challenging way to play against the
chi going but it's just get your pieces
out and play a game kind of way hmm ok I
wonder c5 is this some an idea yeah well
maybe mean
if I take Queen takes Knight e5 bishop d
one night x e6 hmm
hmm yeah not not really leading to
anything Knight d4 I can take this em
right yeah
97 it's just peace at the end
okay so we have a simplified position
some pieces traded like really oh this
is this is surprising that he actually
allows me to take
yeah well this doesn't really help him
ne5 taking is never an option and yeah
this just improves my queen position
here or to g3 as some may be here rugby
7s the move that is getting tricky and
this is the additional problem maybe can
play the kemplevick v5v i am he can play
would be five yeah well this should be
okay for black with Ruby eight how to
continue is there some way to to get
something going
I can I can try to prevent f5 and try to
play for f3 but this is just trying to
get some play it's not necessarily great
meaning it could be could be too
ambitious but ok for I can take it's not
not a problem try to play for you for
checking quite ambitious as mentioned ok
mmm no but this shouldn't be too bad I
mean I have an active active position
now while my king position is the
problem but if it takes I mean I have
two points here that possibly was d5 d6
can can be a better
hmm stop moving
yeah the problem is just the very year
open King they are always possibilities
to to go for Perpetual's and defenses
with repaired with the move repetitions
and so on but it's at not easy for for
blackjack claim yeah this was was a
possibility of course it's that Queen a
form takes King evade he's he's stopping
my porn so I probably need to move the
King threatening Queenie 8 2 2day on
taking on be fine hmm d5 the snide at s
Quincy three
yeah it's very difficult to make any any
headway
kingi 3h forum I'm already pushing it
here probably I should just do nothing
this can easily backfire
hmm
check well he's some were Santa spawn
structure but just a bit
yeah the Queen trade is a draw not a
vegan divide out if he takes then I'm
actually winning with d5 check
check
I wonder if I can somehow get t5 working
getting a pass on
check am I not just promoting you know
I'm just promoting now I think
so let's let's check his sister's d6 or
taking your taking problem yeah I need
to open half of the position open
f5 I can take I'm quick enough time
warning
it's still a game don't believe it ah I
lost some to temp or whatever just the
drawn to Roger Alford draw our third
garage at offered you know we'll know we
can put kings on Janet game draw what
the heck I'm just winning him I'm just
playing it in so many games so this is a
completely winning King important game
of course but i managed to spoil it so
this should be still winning him oops
this draws this is really drawing by one
temple
Kingda for swimming yeah of course I
mean what would the only other move
players King before this is winning
yeah well once you see it it's it's it's
easy check and now this is a completely
different story he takes ages to to get
to the pawn yeah i will add little time
and it was just one move really exactly
one move I mean this is really an insane
with g6 check because this is quite
quite obvious but I was wondering the
success winning as well it's winning as
well now I wasn't completely sure
because sometimes it looks like you're
completely winning but you actually
don't you cannot progress in some way
but I have c4 yeah this is actually the
easiest way to win with the the least
calculation involved ah ok thanks for
watching